buonasera mi chiamo chris cristoforo
torch torchia sono nato negli stati
uniti
cleveland ohio nelle quater e italiane
che chiedo scusa per il mio italiano
stasera ma devo leggere contaminazione
dal latino contaminare inquinare
corrompere originariamente mettere in
contatto da cui insieme e tangere
toccare toccarsi l'uno con l'altro
contaminazione e la presenza di un
componente inglese del reato di una
impurità a volte significa inquinamento
quando vengono danneggiati su larga
scala
gli esseri umani e gli ambienti naturali
decontaminazione e il processo di
depurazione dalle sostanze pericolose ma
non siamo neanche lontanamente bravi a
decontaminare contano siamo invece a
contaminare il centro per la
decontaminazione kotera le è
un'istituzione indipendente con sedia al
belgrado fondato nel 94 come risposta al
clima politico e culturale
della serbia il concetto di
decontaminazione culturale fu reso
pubblico durante le manifestazioni
studentesche del 96 97 a belgrado gli
studenti vennero in centro città dove i
fascisti avevano tenuto un
contromanifestazione per opporsi al
processo democratico
gli studenti de contaminarono la città
pulendo le strade con sapone e spazzole
ma invece di contaminazione e
decontaminazione in un ciclo senza fine
sporcare ripulire sporcare ripulire
riusciamo a rimarginare un uso più
efficace dei batteri cutrali contaminare
creativamente invece di decontaminare
constantemente per migliaia di anni
collettivamente e individualmente
abbiamo ripulito la merda di qualcun
altro forse dobbiamo inventare nuovi
modi di sporcare le cose nel fondare la
sua prima compagnia incontra le nel 74
il registo anglo francese page brook si
pose un'intenzione che poi pratticò
assieme ad artisti che non condivide
condividevano nella lingua navy
ferramenti cutrali e si viaggiano in
africa iran
general triangoli confrontandosi con
storie sempre nuove
l'intenzione scrisse peter brook era
quello di creare cultura nel senso in
cui lo yogurt ecotur un batterio
coltivato per trasformare la sto
sostanza lattiginosa della nostra
società in qualcosa di sano ricco e
gustoso questo trasformazioni operate da
un microcosmo una compagnia teatrale per
esempio diviene un virus cutrale posto
alla giusta temperatura in condizioni
adeguate e potrebbe essere esattamente
il cambiato cambiamento necessario
due tele più pericolose il batterio
della migrazione
mio nonno nacque nel 892 in calabria nel
novecento 12 emigrò negli stati uniti
dove incontrò e sposò mia nonna nel giro
di sette anni
mia nonna avesse i bambini mio padre co
non era il suo fratello gemello len
sì così si chiamavano con helen col e
l'enel vissero in uno famiglie che
parlava italiano
in verità calabrese anche le persone che
vivevano nel quartiere parlavano
italiano si diceva in realtà napolitano
i miei nonni non sapevano né leggere né
scrivere nessuna lingua
mio nonno era un giardiniere un vivaista
aveva un terreno con una piccola sera
una volta quando andammo a trovarlo mio
nonno mi prese per mano e mi portò nella
sera prese giu i ramoscelli le
attorciglia insieme elian kart o con
della carta da giornale bagnato poi di
sotero sotto uno strato di sabbia
lo guardai ripetere l'operazione più
volte parlo senza soste in calabrese
quattro mesi dopo durante un'altra
visita tirò fuori due erano scene e
strappo via la carta di giornale marcita
guardammo le radici che stavano
crescendo dice che le avrebbe piantate è
aspettato non sapeva quale fiore colore
o profumo e profumo che sarebbe sfociato
aveva fatto un innesto di qualcosa che
era al di là da venire
i batteri della lingua dei suoni e delle
storie sono trasportati nelle valigie
dei viaggiatori ogni persona in
movimento milioni
in questo stesso momento contribuisce
allo sviluppo umano alla nostra capacità
di trovare soluzioni sostenibili
la migrazione è un batterio senza il
quale non possiamo vivere
durante uno dei viaggi con il progetto
europeo commerce incontrammo delle
persone che erano fuggite dalla guerra
civile in abkhazia dna giorgiano che
speravano di ritornare presto
invece in quel momento l'unione
sovietica crollò un hotel di lusso quasi
completato
per il leader del partito comunista
divenne invece un alloggio temporaneo
per centinaia di abitazioni quasi 30
anni dopo in quello stesso hotel è nata
la terza generazione essi rimangono
isolati da entrambe lettere madrepatria
bloccati in un hotel da sogno
questo fenomeno si chiama quarantena un
tentativo primitivo di mantenere il
mondo incontaminato al sicuro dagli
impulsi i bisogni le espressioni degli
altri non funziona i sistemi di
sicurezza non sono adeguati
il batterio della migrazione è troppo
forte non può essere fermato
se una società non infetta in quarantena
e un obiettivo primario la migrazione è
una sentenza di morte una malattia
brutale che ci colpisce ovunque per la
quale nessuno ha una cura
e se ci fosse un obiettivo più
importante se la sporche con sequenze
della migrazione in realtà ci vendessero
esigenti inventivi flessibili se
contaminarci l'un l'altro fosse proprio
tutto ciò di cui di cui si chatta in
qual caso netti ciare impasta dire
contaminare il batterio dell'arte le
storie contamino i rom racconti passano
da persona a persona da bocca a bocca
cambiano si adattano al clima del luogo
e alle circostanze formano valori un
esempio
il regista nel dialogo del cef fece
cinque fotografie in un mercato delle
pulci a sofia in bulgaria le mise in
tasca scelse un cognome giorgiano e si
recò nella piazza del mercato nella
città che allah vi ha confini dell'asia
baciano si avvicino a diversi venditori
e mostrò loro le fotografie i miei nonni
lasciarono la giorgia molti anni fa ed
emigrano in bulgaria di sena di alcol
conosci nessuno che gli assomiglia
puoi aiutarmi a trovare la mia famiglia
nel giro di 30 minuti
l'intero mercato era in fermento nel
tentativo di trovare i parenti perduti
dinner bianco avendo uno idee diversi
studiarlo e nassi l'hockey nelle
fotografie senza risultati non si riuscì
ad accordarsi sulla famiglia a cui la
dialogo avrebbe potuto a parte
appartenere 5 vecchie fotografie e una
storia e un intero mercato in una
cittadina della giorgia al confine
conosceva già coinvolto nella ricerca
contagioso delle radici tine bianco ei è
di 6 stessi tutta la cultura è radicata
e narrativi comuni le capitali europee
della contaminazione culturale
io sono stato coinvolto negli ultimi
anni né al lavoro con le capitali
europee della cultura negli ultimi sei
anni ho avuto il privilegio di lavorare
insieme con tre città che hanno vinto il
titolo
ogni volta la fase del sogno è favolosa
tutto è possibile
il programma e le reti e le promesse
politiche sembra come si sta creando una
struttura per un'infezione culturale
qualcosa che potrebbe trasformare la
città in un stura scordella di yogurt
sanno ricco e gustoso un futuro
contaminato visioni su larga scala di
questo tipo sono opportunità harare per
saggiare acque sconosciute e sviluppare
le competenze necessarie per la
contaminazione creativa
c'è qualcosa di straordinario
nel laboratorio con i suoi vetrini e
germi e i continui costruttivi
fallimenti che dà speranza per un breve
e intenso periodo di tempo si accollano
i più sinceri e iniziative cutrali in
un'azione futura comune e infine taranto
ciò che mi ha colpita la prima volta che
sono venuto in questa città a taranto e
si riconferma ogni volte che ivi turno e
che la contaminazione distruttiva che ha
segnato queste città e minacce alla sua
stessa vita genera un'energia opposta
resistenza e via invenzione il pericolo
può scatenare una immensa creatività
come ho visto io stesso agli angoli e ai
confini di europa dell'europa dei nei
balcani a belfast nelle periferie di
fronte a una situazione disperata
accettiamo la sfida
cominciamo dall'inizio ripensiamo questo
incredibile città che taranto è stato
abusata dalla avidità ma può diventare
la capitale europea della contaminazione
creativa la città antica di taranto
mi è stato detto era una città chiusa
fortificato costruito e ivi construito
generazione dopo generazione le stesse
pietre usate più e più volte
questa era una strategia fondata sulla
paura adesso serve un altro e strategia
servono due batteri migrazione e arte
nuove voci nuovi occhi nuovi suoni
taranto deve aprirsi accogliere coloro
che cercano un nuovo inizio ai confini
dell'europa abbracciati dal mare è il
posto perfetto per cominciare la mia
invenzione del progetto europeo
per realizzare un sogno che va bene
oltre il profitto e libro mercato per
costruire invece un laboratorio urbano
dove siamo contaminati e trasformati dal
nostro incontro con l'altro e dalle
ceneri di una società industriale e
morente nasce un movimento un'azione
collettiva che demolisce la cultura
della morte
grazie buono sermoni
[Applauso]
[Musica]
christophe grazie crisi grazie
[Applauso]